tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo video
sono fa vj oggi siamo tornati sud
redoubt dopo dio non so quanto è passato
forse non ero neanche nato vieni a
continuare la traccia amori fermati dove
c'erano i massi non si poteva sentire
lot named per il salvataggio mastrandrea
cazzo beh ok perfetto ha così proprio il
figo carino poi di potere sconosciuto
sta arrabbiando dagli oggetti
collezionati si cacci io non mi ricordo
un tasto in croce di sto gioco comunque
eravamo usciti l'asta scuola ci aveva
messo gli anni per uscire a sta roba
non è proprio così il giardino pd è che
si è cresciuta anche dell'erba né beh mi
piace ha messo anni a fare il seguito
figurati sono è cresciuta l'air dove
riesco a fare i file che stanno
seriamente chi è che sta ridendo room
carisa risate a parte che sarà questo
buongiorno come come gli permette di
toccare una donna lorido stronzo che
mikati pio a calci d uso come pallone al
ragazzi ragazzi sto cazzo ragazzi mi
stanno stuprando degli gnomi merda via
via via via via scorso perché ci sono
degli gnomi che tentano di stuprare una
donna ragazzi aiuto ai canti gli amici
insomma perché via via via via manova
fast a tutti cazzo sono matti o mio
ritardo tutti bastardi ci avete tutti
profilo facebook per micah p st rovinati
qualche stronzo cosa tip altri e delle
persone cioè io questo non è un horror
una presa per il culo strafavorite tutti
niente con comic torna il mio telefono
il mio tele non è in garanzia se me lo
rubano bastardo mi ha rubato l'iphone
questa classifice elfi adesso ma la mio
telefono ma come chiama la mamma del
cazzo mai mi ha rubato tutto la borsa
che stronzo ma no che ladri stanno tanto
non sai come si sblocca al telefono
notifica ruby cosa ruby e poi centro cei
tampax nella borsa che il caso tempo
perfetto allora capisci con un gioco
inizia bene quando dopo un minuto di
gioco da rubato borsa iphone anche le
mutande forse non c'è più mi chiamo
vedevo l'ora che la giornata
mancavano queste cose che mimì fottevano
la roba meraviglia
giorno è perché ho visto degli gnomi
passare ma rubato tipo l'iphone sta
sviluppando dal pozzo sto alta zio che
cos'è con cosa stai sniffando un
cadavere con uno scherzavo è non si
picchiano mica ti denuncio però devo
dire che ha dei movimenti che sono
veramente sexy via via via via via più
forza c'è un tipo che sta tentando di
violentarmi no vabbè mi ha violentato la
pazienza tutti dentro di violentarmi
questo gioco perché è violenta no ancora
ascolta specie di scimmia bocca evoluta
che cazzo inciampato ma manco la testata
di materazzi ha così violentandone che
prendo no no no no no no no [ __ ]
se facessi fargli una foto a sto
deficiente la manderei direttamente alla
polizia ma non posso via via via veloce
dentro chiudi come si chiude non si
chiude la porta [ __ ] non si chiama
donna che più è stato dato al muro
alzati fa qualcosa mutati fondi via
porca [ __ ] cosa ti guardi dove cazzo
vado dove nardò ragazzi madonna le botti
in faccia corrive vado alla porta se la
porta a porta
chiudi chiudi giu dov'è adesso non c'è
più
ah cazzo prendi l'ombrello chiudi brava
che se ce l'ho fatta dopo ora ecco è
trovato un bel michia seduto fixed
ombrello lurido chirico a venire ma se
ci sta tutto dentro per il culo lurido
maniaco che non sa dove dove è andato ma
è sparito dei ragazzi ciechi nei
videogiochi a delle armi tipo bazooka
lame katane io io io ho un ombrello è
una suoneria di un telefono giorno la
madre emma mio di ascolto al suo maestro
aspettavi tipo il busto e che non è
passato ci si mette la vita ad aspettare
qualcosa qua un aquilone
no ancora ma vaff arco madonna che
ombrellate in faccia si è rotto londra
madonna che botta carrera caristo
maniaco di merda ancora
se non per mia palla brava si avrà così
più forte dove italia la prossima volta
nel dire tano direttamente lo zio
crollato il pavimento bravissimo ragazzo
è crollato il pavimento
com ma se ne accorge ma non è mica il
[ __ ] solo maniaco non è che non ti
vede o non ti vedo non mi ha visto
ragazzi non mi sta vedendo striscia
madonna che figo non abbiamo la fig
amici hanno cambiato in meglio sto gioco
è una figata pazzesca solo che ho perso
l'iphone
buongiorno ascolti fratello non è che
sono tua per forza e ritorna su youporn
che è meglio uno di quei no no non è
questo sito cori vai via scappa perda
navy button ha manco l'esorcista
certo che però mica sei un disastro
dunque vai cadi sembra che ci abbia le
convulsioni me non me ne frega un cazzo
corri il mio iphone lurido bastardo dami
l'iphone da mila iphone basta col
riprendi lo fai qualcosa ma no cosa si
sta alzando i ragazzi in situazione di
merda e corri maledizione del mio
telefono l'ho preso a zero euro in
abbonamento con la promozione mio dio
non può sopra
e cosa ferma preso sto strona preso cosa
ti tocchi lurido maniaco ba avrai che
scappa scappa si fa qualcosa che ci ha
dato che il mio telefono
vabbè mi chiama c'è qualcosa che regge
in supporto con l'affitto
crolla tutto anche le persone scorta è
morto è vero che non muore
quanto sei figo bellissimo fratel sei
veramente uno gnocco ascoltavi
consigliere pò di palestra è perché mi
piaccia i dei muscoli che sono tipo
reattivi quanto quelli di mia nonna
donnas di fare cadaveri per fuoco fame
infami sto piace tornati di fare calare
ancora ma basta col li prego nasto lord
fares dell'utenza padre vado chiudi no
non chiudere gori si chiuse qualcosa è
successo niente mi deve stuprare non c'è
verso chi successo è rimasto è rimasto
lì è morto è morto ragazzi ci ho fatto
l'ho ucciso io ei miei poteri
sovrannaturali incredible io giorno non
mi tocchi perchè giuro che la denuncio
anche lei è ecco vedi che la gente si
cali addosso quando gli parli di
annunciare che roba bravo ascoltami zio
o un avvocato che ti giuro ti faccio
passare le pene dell'inferno
ecco stupro eccoli a 90 preciso grande e
bella zio al maniaco stuprato quanto ci
godo
ma no l'ha rimesso su allora sì bastardo
impaziente di merda magari messo su
dimmi che muore di mica niente continua
deve continuare allora un pericolo ma
perché
ma perché è in grandissima ma che bello
quanto ci godo
e sorride forli ragazzi della cosa fa ma
da brava brava brava uccidi lucide si da
grandissimo sono vivo soliva scusate
sono una donna mi sono iniziato con le
tette adesso non rimane che trovare il
tipo che mi ha [ __ ] l'iphone però io
voglio il mio non è che barattiamo
myphone macchine fatto che la grazie a
te la foto è non è che poi ci ripensi e
tela viene a prendere no nella foto chi
cazzo si sta facendo i salti di là
perché sono che si fa i set by va
indietro ma ho trovato macchina
fotografica ma buongiorno aventi un
qualcosa di mio so che vi siete crati
profilo facebook tutti e tre per mettere
le fornaci bastardi di quella ora la
borsa mia mio dio di gucci tutta roba
ecco quello telefoni o cazzo sorridi
selphy sta sorridendo avvenuto el scolta
zio nessuno ti ha mai detto ma te lo
dico io c'hai un pene che sembra un
ornitorinco però vabbè però fatti una
vita perché sei pronto se so che posso
fuji ho preso la borsa al telefono
grazie a dio ricatto sia mi chiama musa
google maps fa qualcosa zio che bella
torcia mica saperlo prima non ragazza
ovviamente dove cazzo si è finiti alla
rotonda fare in scena
quando sentite gridare un maniaco
scappata la vostra destra perché mi
ballano pure le tette quando corpo
bellissimo questo gioco salve la madonna
sono arrivati in paradiso quanto costi
jia foto profilo questa è poi mita
dimetti ph fa vj foto ap la madonna che
puttanata latella mia sei veramente sexy
però non è cosa faccio posso toccarti
così una brava così per il calendario
aprile maggio
facciamo giugno brava ecco perfetto
luglio si sa viene dopo agosto vai è
stato un piacere ragazzi a lavorare con
voi
adesso devo andare però è stato
veramente continuate così che siete
bravissimi vuoi una foto anche tu zio i
gatti incazzato ma ciao 1 nudo lo sai
che ho visto dei maniaci si giorni posso
farti una foto al non c'è il pene bene
un altro buddha ma basta ha ordinato
anche la pizza al buddha film madonna
che bello
ok va bene ho fatto la foto alla statua
che ad affidarsi acceso anche la candela
li mortacci della candela come come
l'altra volta lo spegne e le candele
farle bellissimo e un altro buddha
ma basta che cazzo te che cazzo è
successo ragazze e ragazzi ci siete non
ci sono più le tipe gnocche merda non
sono lasciate scappare così non mi hanno
manco dato il numero di morta a cison se
vado a spegnere
oh cazzo è diventato come trasformare un
posto da un paradiso al cimitero in tre
secondi sono un fenomeno mica tutorial
proprio non seriamente cosa è successo
dio ti ringraziano ciatti pagnotta
quella enorme scalzi sa già che ci dai
il tuo numero almeno tu perché almeno
sei rimasto solo tu se ti va è quanto 96
occhi almeno una volta perché vengo
ascoltata ti faccio una foto poi in
qualche modo è la madonna al balcone
notai il numero adesso so se lo sono
fatto merda non scherza non lo voglio
più non lo voglio più sono vodafone non
posso aggiungere i numeri tim
mi dispiace ma seriamente che cazzo
successo mio dio
oh mio dio oddio via via via via via
veloce veloce cazzo che a [ __ ] quanto
sei brutto ria carri macchiato ragazzi
che sarà prima parte di tre d'auto spero
che vi sia piaciuto l'ato 2 che è una
figata pazzesca c'è il primo numero un
cazzo il confronto è bellissimo conti
volano il prossimo episodio mannaggia la
minchia che non mi hanno dato il numero
è va be me ne farò una ragione di vita
tutti ragazzi servizio è piaciuto la
solita sotto commento mi piace anche a
pagine facebook e con i video trattare
stizia nei prestiti si definì ci fidiamo
prossimo vinto belle ragazze